so now we're going to show you some
video from cnn cnn used to be a place of
journalism it's a partisan democrat
outfit uh and here's a guy by the name
of don lamont and uh he's struggling
he's struggling because
there are bad people out there and and
he's trying to be a journalist
we sit around and we talk about these
things and we we want to give this false
equivalence to democrats and republicans
that is not where we are right now
republicans are doing something that is
very
dangerous to our society and we have to
acknowledge that we have to acknowledge
that as americans we must acknowledge
that as journalists
because if we don't we're not doing our
jobs we cannot sit here and pretend like
well you republicans it's a cut them a
break let's we want to hear whatever
they have a lot to answer for in this
moment
a lot to answer for what happened with
the former president of the united
states whether you agree with abortion
rights or not why they have taken back a
right that was what the you know that
was granted to american women for 50
years we have a former member of the
oath keepers
who is saying we are in very dangerous
territories
territory we have a history professor
who is telling us right now that the gop
is becoming more and more associated
with extremists
guys a history professor doesn't like
the republicans sweet jesus send out
something on the wire a history
professor
a professor at a university who's a
partisan hack who doesn't like
republicans this is incredible this is
absolutely staggering and i'm freaking
out guys
so ridiculous first off let me just
qualify with this i used to be friends
with don he's been on the show he was a
decent guy he really was something broke
him trump broke him
black lives matter broke him i don't
know what broke him uh but way back when
actually when i had him on the show he
was openly talking about how uh islamic
violence radical islamic violence
against gay people is a problem i'm
pretty sure he wouldn't talk about that
anymore because he's gone full woke but
he's everything he said there you could
completely do the reverse of and it
would make more sense the republicans
have gone extreme well wait a minute you
mean the democrats have gone extreme
when they locked everybody down and how
in all the democrat-run cities there's
no law and order and lockdowns
all that stuff like any of that
then he's the republicans have to deal
with january 6. oh yes that a thing that
riot that lasted a couple hours that was
completely disorganized that nobody
brought any weapons to and blah blah
blah blah they have to deal with that
then there's this history professor he's
freaking out about the
and he and i that he dares sit there
with his fake news man glasses and his
perfectly pressed shirt and jacket i do
my own by the way okay that's why my
collars are sometimes a little relaxed
but that's my vibe
but his are very perfect because he's
got 18 people in charge of his shirt and
his glasses and all that stuff um that
he sits there and pretends that we as
journalists
time to be non-partisan is over we're
journalists that we have to save the
republic
it's so bananas it's just so ridiculous
it's and nobody's buying it i know no
one's buying it but the reason i wanted
to show you that clip is because i think
it gets to the heart of what these
people think that they are they think oh
perhaps there was a time when we could
have been honest it's just so odd that
he's saying it out loud maybe there was
a time where we could be honest maybe
there was a time where we could debate
things but now there's so many nazis
over there there's the january 6th thing
there's a history professor over there
we've got to do something to save the
republic it's complete drivel drivel
nonsense